Google Cloud updates you can deploy
pytorch models on vertex AI in just a
few clicks because with pre-built
pytorch serving containers that means
less code no need to write Docker files
and faster time to production logs for
Network load balancing and logs for
internal TCP UDP load balancing are now
in GA they're aggregated per connection
and exported in near real time which
provides you with useful and
customizable information the freshly
published anthos hybrid Cloud
architecture reference design guide
provides opinionated guidance to help
you deploy anthos in a hybrid
environment it even addresses some of
the common challenges that you might
encounter and you can get that and all
stories in the links below thanks for
watching